[Música]
repaso de las noticias de la economía
con daniela hablando otra vez un saludo
para usted daniel holaaaa angela vamos a
volver para hablar del foro económico de
davos y como ucrania pues sigue siendo
protagonista y señora pues de davos de
este pueblo en los alpes suizos es el
escenario de nuevo para la charla de 4
días dedicada a la economía un evento
que se reanuda de manera presencial
después de una pausa de dos años debido
a la pandemia de kobe 19 no ha sido
invitado a ninguno de los 270 paneles de
discusión
de hecho la denominada casa de rusia y
muy tradicional en este foro económico
en este lugar también fue transformado
en su fachada ahora dice la casa de los
crímenes de guerra y presenta imágenes
que evidencian los delitos de los que el
kremlin está acusado de cometer una de
las primeras intervenciones en fuera del
presidente de ucrania volodymyr selectos
es necesario cambiar el enfoque no
reaccionar sino actuar y actuar de forma
preventiva y no sólo para adaptarnos a
las nuevas realidades que tenemos sino
para crear nuevas herramientas nuevos
precedentes presente ante sí pero
tendríamos que hacer eso si no se
hubieran escuchado el año pasado y
aplicado un paquete de sanciones justo
preventivo y completo contra la
federación rusa que podría derribar a
cualquier agresor
ucrania llegó primero pero también hay
otros temas que se analizan esta semana
daniela cuáles son si pues la guerra en
ucrania desde luego el gran protagonista
pero para los asistentes del foro hay
mucho más que abordar aunque sean
también efectos colaterales de esta
guerra por ejemplo el aumento
vertiginoso de los precios de los
alimentos también del combustible el
cambio climático la desigualdad y las
persistentes crisis de salud pero quizás
uno de los más apremiantes desde la
inseguridad alimentaria mundial de hecho
naciones unidas hizo un llamado hoy para
reabrir el puerto de odessa afectado
también por esta guerra
justo cuando crees que la situación no
podría empeorar frente a hace un año
teníamos etiopía luego y ahora el
granero del mundo ahora debido a esta
crisis estamos tomando comida de los
hambrientos para dársela a los
hambrientos es absolutamente un modo de
crisis que creen que va a pasar cuando
se toma una nación que normalmente
cultiva suficiente para alimentar a 400
millones de personas y la dejas de lado
a eso se suman los costos de combustible
los costos de alimento los costos de
envío es devastador no sólo para
nuestras operaciones sino también para
la seguridad alimentaria mundial vamos a
dejar de davos por un momento para
hablar del informe de oxfam sobre
desigualdad daniela claro y que presenta
precisamente justo en el marco de este
evento no necesariamente allí pero sí a
propósito de lo que se está hablando y
es que esta organización benéfica con
sede en nairobi hizo énfasis en que
superada la peor etapa del cob y de 19 a
ahora la guerra está empujando a
personas más personas a la pobreza
extrema
oxfam cree que en 2022 unos 263 millones
de personas más caerán en la pobreza
extrema qué quiere decir esto según el
banco mundial son aquellos que viven con
menos del 1 a menos de 19 dólares por
día y también hace la comparación con el
número de multimillonarios que estima
hoy en unos 2700 de esto es casi un 30%
más que a comienzos de la crisis
sanitaria además todos ellos tienen una
fortuna estimada de 12 a 7 billones de
dólares y también tenemos de tema sobre
las cripto monedas no están invitadas
oficialmente al foro de davos pero si
son protagonistas claro no están
invitadas porque esto es una tecnología
recordemos que todavía no está regulada
sin embargo los representantes de las
empresas involucradas en blogs amy en
general en cripto monedas se tomaron la
calle principal de davos alquilaron casi
la mitad de los pabellones disponibles a
pesar del reciente desplome del valor de
las monedas digitales justo a las
afueras del cordón de seguridad
principal del centro de conferencias hay
inclusive un puesto gratuito de bitcoin
pixar un evento paralelo a la reunión
anual de líderes empresariales y
políticos en el centro turístico alpino
el objetivo es alentar una adopción más
rápida de la tecnología que una campaña
de comunicación que se produce justo
cuando la script o monedas han perdido
cientos de miles de millones de dólares
en valor desde comienzos de este mes y
ya para su cifra del día de daniela
hagamos un poco de contexto precisamente
porque hay una gran crisis en eeuu por
cuenta de la falta de leche de fórmula
en los supermercados y esto es muy grave
sobre todo porque hay bebés que dependen
de la leche de fórmula cuando no son
tolerantes a otro tipo de alimentos
claro y es que ha habido una una escasez
en este país debido al cierre de una de
las plantas de uno de los grandes
productores de leche de fórmula por eso
la cifra del día son los 35 mil
kilogramos que llegan desde europa
directo hasta eeuu para suplir esta
escasez bueno y muchos de ellos danielle
además no serán vendidos ni siquiera en
supermercados sino que van a ser
directamente entregados a los foros
lugares sí señor entregados por el
gobierno son aproximadamente 500 mil
dosis de teteros las que podrán suplir
con este cargamento que llega desde
europa y después de este tema cuáles son
los indicadores de la jornada mire las
bolsas están mayormente al alza el día
de hoy iniciando con las bolsas
asiáticas como tokio que cerró con
ascenso también toma un pequeño respiro
la gran mayoría de parqués europeos a
pesar de que la inflación el aumento de
tasas de interés la guerra en un cráneo
la desaceleración de la economía china y
todos muchos factores están castigando
en general a las acciones tener a
gracias a usted por este completo
resumen y mañana estarán pero con robert
sí señora y con louise bueno pues vamos
a continuar con más noticias en directo
americanos vamos directo a parís